merci Monsieur le Premier Ministre la
parole est à Monsieur George fenec oui
je vous remercie monsieur le Président
mes chers collègues ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'Intérieur
monsieur le ministre le 14 juillet 2016
la France a été à nouveau cruellement
frappée cette fois-ci en province dans
la ville de Nice au nom de l'islam
radical le tragique bilancore provisoire
fait état de 84 morts et de 202 blessés
il n'est pas sans nous rappeler la tuée
du Bataclan en novembre dernier ses 89
morts et ses centaines de blessés sur la
quelle la commission d'enquête que j'ai
présidé don notre collègue Sébastien
Pietra Santa était le rapporteur
appointé très précisément toutes les
failles et dysfonctionnement notamment
des services de renseignement français
et européens j'observe d'ailleurs avec
soulagement que dans une interview
journal Le Monde de ce soir vous
déclarez enfin ouvert à l'organisation
d'une meilleure coordination et partage
du renseignement à Nice c'est la
question des failles dans la sécurité
mise en place à l'occasion de ce grand
événement à laquelle il vous incom de
répondre mais de grâce monsieur le
ministre n'invoquez plus l'union sacrée
et je ne sais quel esprit polémique pour
échapper aux questions relevant de vos
responsabilités ministérielles c'est
l'honneur de notre démocratie c'est
aussi le rôle et le devoir de
l'opposition de vous poser ces questions
toutes ces questions l'interrogation est
d'autant plus légitime que cet entat
attentat revendiqué par daesh s'est
produit alors que nous étions déjà sous
le régime d'état d'urgence censé nous
protéger monsieur le ministre les
victimes et leurs familles martyrisé sur
la promedade des Anglais vous demande
légitimement des explications auxquelles
elles ont droit enfin comme si vous ne
manquez jamais une occasion de le
rappeler et vous aveit raison en matière
de terrorisme le risque zéro n'existe
pas escanis l'état a bien pris toutes
les mesures de sécurité qui s'imposaient
pour parer ce type
d'attentat merci la parole est à
Monsieur Bernard casazenu ministre de
l'Intérieur monsieur
le monsieur le député après le député
rudissal vous me posez une question
extrêmement précise à laquelle je veux
répondre avec précision puisque comme
vous l'avez dit à juste titre nous
devons la vérité aux victimes et l'État
dans la responsabilité qui est la sienne
doit rendre des comptes avec le niveau
de précision qui lui incombe lorsqu'il
s'agit de ses compétences d'abord vous
soullignez l'excellent travail qui a été
réalisé par Sébastien Pira Santa dans
son rapport vous indiquez que je déclare
dans le monde aujourd'hui être ouvert à
une réforme du renseignement je veux
juste vous dire que je vous ai très
agréablement reçu la semaine dernière et
que j'ai eu à plusieurs reprises
l'occasion de vous donner cette
information pour ce qui concerne la
sécurité à Nice le Premier ministre
vient sur la base d'éléments extrêmement
précis de vous donner les informations
qui sont les informations réel il y a eu
quatre réunions deux réunions entre la
sécurité publique et la police
municipale et deux réunions entre la
préfecture et la ville de Nice ces
quatre réunion avait pour objectif de
définir très précisément les mesures à
prendre pour atteindre dans un contexte
de menace concernant tout le pays il n'y
avait aucune information concernant des
menaces spécifiques à Nice des mesures
appropriées c'est dans ce casadre que
l'État a défini le niveau des effectifs
de police qui devait être mis en place
sur la Promenade des Anglais et que la
ville de Nice dans sa compétence elle
est organisatrice de la manifestation
elle a compétence sur la voirie
municipale a pris par un arrêté qui est
un arrêté du 11 juillet l'ensemble des
mesures qui lui incombé une contestation
a eu lieu sur le fait que les effectif
de police nationale était bien présent
j'ai fait reconstituer la liste des
policiers nominatifs présents à partir
des ordres d'opération et des mains
courantes je communiquerai ces éléments
au procureur de la République puis au
juges d'instruction lorsqu'il aura été
désigné parce que ces éléments
correspondent à la stricte vérité et ils
ne correspondent pas au contenu des
polémiques qui n'auraient pas eu lieu
d'être qui ont mis en cause injustement
le préfet le directeur départemental de
la sécurité publique les polici
je prot TS